new in theaters this weekend the
gentlemen and the turning what will you
see this is your weekend ticket sweet
Mary Jane is my advice you avoid on the
other hand is and always has been the
destroyer of world you're out of touch
and I would like you to consider an
offer I am not for sale when a marijuana
drug lord decides he wants to retire and
sell off his business an assortment of
criminals come out of the woodwork to
make a bid for or strong-arm him out of
his business
the gentleman is directed by Guy Ritchie
and sees him working once again with
Charlie Hunnam and Hugh Grant also
Matthew McConaughey's in it this movies
for you if in an action movie is what
you seek this weekend you like the
bombastic filmmaking of Guy Ritchie or
if you're hoping to figure out what
Matthew McConaughey said here
must of minute my phones
the house why not don't wanna hello
shouldn't be in here
a new nanny has tasked with taking care
of two orphaned children but soon she
realized there is something disturbing
going on as the children won't say what
happened to the last nanny also there's
a spider in it this movie is for you if
a horror movie sounds good to you this
weekend you're a fan of thin wolf heart
or if like me you're disappointed that
while researching this movie I couldn't
find a nickname for Finn wolf hard fans
like wolf Packer Finn fans are hard
heads that is your weekend ticket will
you see and come back next week for a
tale as all this time but not beating
the Beast